[Music]
Celine Dion drops a new music video with
a surprise superhero cameo what's left
to do with these broken pieces on the
yup Ryan Reynolds as Deadpool teamed up
with Queen Celine for her new song ashes
featured on the Deadpool 2 soundtrack
it may come as a surprise to see
Deadpool sashay across the stage in an
interpretive dance while the legendary
singer belts out a powerful ballad to an
empty theater but the Marvel superhero
is not half bad the music video was shot
at the Colosseum at Caesars Palace the
same venue where Celine hosts her Las
Vegas residency as a singer as me to be
able to share that kind of love on stage
people think that when they come and see
my show it it they know what to expect
in a way they come to hear those songs
that was the most beautiful performance
ever seen nice thank you so much
this is Deadpool - not Titanic alright
you're at like an 11 we need to get you
down to a five five and a half tops just
phone it in listen this thing only goes
to 11 so beat it spider-man god I should
have asked in sync
[Music]
[Applause]